welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Marvel head Kevin Feige
revealed some major details about the
future of the multiverse in the MCU
earlier this month at Brazil's comic-con
that slipped beneath the radar he's some
cryptic language that he hasn't used
before to talk about the ways Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness and
Disney Plus phase four series like Wanda
vision and Falcon the Winter Soldier
will all connect and blow this universe
wide open not enough people are talking
about this and before I begin quick
thanks to Marvel collect my tops for
sponsoring this breakdown
stick around later for some details on a
chance to win some very cool prizes
shout out to Rigg Raton in for tweeting
me a link to the panel so that we can
break down the new details we learned in
this episode of inside marvels
okay when Feige took the stage in brazil
he confirmed that two Marvel Disney Plus
series had begun production we've
already started shooting two of them and
and they're very very special we know
that one of those series is the Falcon
in the Winter Soldier coming to Disney
Plus fall 2020 with some leaks at photo
showing the John Walker US agent at a
football game and others showing signs
listing samson development rebuilding
cities after the blip but the second
series obviously must be one division
which comes right after the falcon
Winter Soldier in spring 2021 right
before Doctor Strange to the multiverse
of madness Feige was asked some very
interesting questions and gave some very
interesting answers I assume that
wondrous powers are going to develop
maybe to create his new reality and in
the comics Wonder has such a rich
variety of powers connected to the
mutants a name that I'm not even sure
we've said in the MCU yet but we
absolutely make a big deal of in the
show which is that Wanda is in fact the
Scarlet Witch and what does that mean
tirely fun entirely funny somewhat scary
and will have repercussions for the
entire future face for be MCU
Feige goes on to mention some influences
from the Tom King vision comic book
series which featured vision in a
suburban setting in a cameo and he said
that we're gonna get a cameo of Sparky
the dog from that run but then IB
redirects from the Tom King influences
to suggest a different multiverse
direction for the one division series
it's it's it's only just inspired by
that series but goes into a different
direction based on where we are after
endgame with the MCS the multiverse is
kind of the future and the way you can
connect maybe order
franchises the multiverse is the next
step in the evolution the MCU and Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness is
going to crack it wide open in ways that
will have repercussions for a Disney
Plus series just before it that's not
Wanda vision and for movies just after
it yeah interesting
Feige is suggesting that after Asgard
and after the cosmic explorations of the
Guardians movies and after time-travel
an in-game now the multiverse is the
next bonkers plot structure that shows
like one division are going to explore
not just one division one Disney Plus
series set before it which must be the
Falcon of Winter Soldier so I'll explain
what this
like but first thank you to marvel
collect bye tops for sponsoring this
episode
unlock a world where you can collect and
trade Marvel characters you can bring
your collection life by earning awards
for completing sets trade and lower
level or duplicate cards to receive more
special limited ones and much more new
collectibles are released every day
Marvel collect by Tots is available in
both the iTunes App Store and Google
Play Store worldwide and is free to
download in free to play December is a
fan Appreciation Month and to celebrate
it in app tops digital is giving away
one free collectible every day of the
month for Marvel collect users to
collect and complete the saddest 30
users can collect cards some days in the
month that have already passed even if
they didn't sign them that day so check
it out I've collected four of the fant
appreciation cards I just need four and
I'll have all five I'll be checking back
in January we're gonna get there by
completing these steps you can enter for
a chance to win $1,000 worth of Disney
com gift cards $250 Midtown comics
digital gift card and $100 worth of
in-app currency just click the link in
the description to download marvel
collect app register a username and then
collect the 5 at the end appreciation
character cards located in the free
section of the pack store once all five
are collected you'll be eligible to win
the giveaway be sure to follow at tops
Marvel on Twitter and ad tops digital
and Instagram download Marvel clegg to
buy tops digital trading card app to
start collecting and trading your
favorite characters with fans around the
world the app is free to play and new
cards are released every day download
now from the link below okay so in these
post in-game times what is Feige hinting
at by the multiverse being introduced as
early as the Falcon and Winter Soldier
well notice by Gea's reaction when the
interviewer brought up the idea of Wanda
using her powers to project dual
realities god I love it when
interviewers are actual nerds who know
to ask the right questions psyches like
oh [ __ ] this thing George Stephanopoulos
this person is geeked out over the same
comic so I have and they know exactly
where I want to go with this [ __ ] so I
think this is confirmation that at least
some of the reality that we're gonna see
in one division will be a projected
alternate reality manifested by Wanda
Maximoff sorcery as her powers enable
her to do with the Marvel Comics have
discussed before the likelihood of
Marvel Studios adapting the famous
Scarlet Witch House of M storyline from
the comics which features Wanda out of
control as she resets all the reality
with their psychic abilities this could
be one way the MCU introduces the
multiverse to us we've known the MC
multiverse exists as early as
first Doctor Strange movie and it
displayed other dimensions and abstract
trippy forms but alternate dimensions
within the multiverse don't have to look
like a black light painting they can
also just be just like ours but just a
little different still grounded ultimate
realities we're like people just
pronounced Jaguar as jagwire that's the
ultimate reality I'm from it's called
Jacksonville Florida no Peggy has been
emphasizing how one division will be
very much a post endgame series and how
did in game lead Wanda heartbroken
damaged that's okay her mental struggles
could lead this witch to conjure an
alternate reality within the multiverse
where she envisioned living a happy old
school sitcom life like the one imagined
by Elliott and that season two episode
of mr. robot you watch mr. robot right
you should it rocks
I'm even more curious to see what role
the multiverse could play in the Falcon
and Winter Soldier which until now seems
like the buddy-cop espionage series
about super soldiers trying to clear
their names against morally bankrupt
government sponsored counterparts but if
you think about it Sam's shield - give
him - on my old cap did in a sense come
from the multiverse depending on which
version of timeline logic you would
interpret the final scene of endgame
with the right one or the wrong one old
man cap lived his life with Peggy Carter
in an alternate history within the
multiverse and then after that life was
complete he returned to our timeline to
hand off the shield but what happened in
that alternate history what has this old
man seen grabs old cap will continue to
play a small role in this series as a
kind of mentor figure similar to elderly
Bruce Wayne and Batman Beyond with his
unusual history offering us all some
insights into the ripple aberrations
from other timelines and multiverse that
we might see in a future Marvel
installment because Feige also hinted at
the multiverse concepts of Doctor
Strange and multiverse madness will
affect the movies just after it which
according to the pace for calendar could
refer to Thor 11 Thunder which does
feature the alternate Thor Jane Foster
or the next movie after the Disney Sony
deal was reached Tom Hollands third
spider-man movie with cap and Peggy
together in an alternate life maybe that
could have led to the super-soldier
program applied to the UK with Captain
Britain
Brian Radek was mentioned in the subtle
audio Easter egg an end game which could
lead to Billy Braddock spider UK in the
third spider-man film and that maybe
could have been set up by Peter holding
the tower bridge shield in the makeshift
maze in the far from home scene comment
down below with how you want the
multiverse to influence pays for follow
me on Instagram and Twitter
at a boss and subscribe to new rock
start some pretence of Ares Daniela
thanks for joining me
[Music]
you